bella tutti ragazzi benvenute questo
nuovi che sono fra i generi queste il
parco acquatico numero uno al mondo cioè
mina categorizzato come il numero uno al
mondo di prodotti parchi acquatici
ecco avete presente il parco acquatico
che andati coda volti dei vostri amici è
una mera fa schifo il confronto fa
veramente pena
ecco questo è il numero uno al mondo
vediamo se effettivamente così
non sapevo fosse il numero uno al mondo
tanto abbiamo questo salve se però non
mi venite a dose grazie parrucca di una
vita e che adesso stiamo facendo questa
cosa che è un giro dove tu stai sul
gommone e giri e niente ragazza è creato
un ingorgo
è così che succede nelle tubature quando
si intasano caravale all'essere umano
che bello soprattutto lui spiega mi
spiega che in questa face cosa fare cosa
fai ti spiegano cosa fare cosa fatta no
no che predano che predano che fredda
dei possino gesù cristo
ok tutto il percorso finito ma salita
dovrebbe esserci uno scivolo che adesso
blog
allora fa quando si guarda era una cosa
tranquilla fino al gatto e vabbè che
male c'è male
e vabbè
[Musica]
praticamente certa piscina gigante ma
guarda quante cross a una persona e
gigantesca continua fino alla fine della
morte qua in questo cancello qua a una
certa ora si apre e arrivano delle onde
gigantesche che travolgono tutta la
gente adesso lo faccio vedere marone che
è un raduno dei mail che vorrei prendere
questa cosa perché non avete idea della
figata porca vacca ecco l'arrivo
guardaroba
domani la gente morire affogata e poi il
biglietto però è vietato affogare quindi
il bagnino ti fischia prova da allora mi
spiego la situazione per i mente ci sono
siamo arrivati noi da lì e ci sono un
miliardo e mezzo di ombrelloni un
miliardo e mezzo di ombrelloni ve lo
giuro e per trovare un posto 11 che
fosse uno quando di mettere quanto il
giro ci si mette tv geo raga un'ora ci
guardate mente piccolo una persona
immagine uno stadio
palmi
[Musica]
sì
no ho regalato sfigato ci sono le foche
è fighissimo
ma perché non essere ancora riuscito a
praga mi piace delle foche è bellissimo
sto posto epoca aspetta che ecco la
madonna il nostro the sun brani marini
poco quel che sono
quanto giuro su dio che normalmente non
ho mai visto dice così grosso e
incredibilmente gigante comunque da lì
escono le onde con questa piscina ho
notato che gli esseri umani si
esercitano a diventare poche foca
simulator i miei diciotto realisti
perche non fa veramente caldo giuro che
non ho mai votato sembrano essere
sembrati le cartoline avete presente le
cartoline quelle solo che non è una
cartolina c'è giuro sembra veramente un
paesaggio da cartolina è fighissimo
c'è praticamente di più alto dello
scivolo ripido che ho fatto c'è solo
quella roba lì se magro e mi sa che non
è un'altra ecco quello a quello il mio
scivolo di prima se adesso mi fanno la
cortesia ad aprire i cancelli ci siamo
un po di onde da porca vacca con
l'arrivo in parata europa questa è tutta
questa è la e la ri ricreo del titanic
i ragazzi questo è il parco acquatico
number one nel mondo spero vi sia
piaciuto il video e se non fosse che i
capelli miei si riducono così dopo che
si bagnano il mondo sarebbe un posto
migliore però questa è un'altra storia
mi dispiace un poster video è uscito
corto però il mirata e non potevo
neanche registrare dentro il parco l'ho
fatto perché sono trasgressivo quindi
anche se corto sono uscito a portarvi un
po con me
laddove possibile senza buttare mille
euro di videocamera nel cesso
anzi nell'acqua delle piscine e ho
rischiato un sacco di farlo tra
parentesi
nonostante questo vi lascio il link in
descrizione prevedere del resto del blog
che ho fatto a tenerife perché questo
parco si trova a tenerife che ho
pubblicato già cinque giorni fa dove ho
fatto anche il parapendio insomma lo
siete perso mi son cagato addosso per
niente quindi guardate le muove per culo
grazie ai ragazzi sia video cresciuto
giorno raggiunge di pace che si mettono
che è sera secoli si discute e non ci
vediamo al belga
[Musica]